et nous est sauvée en grande bretagne a
fait la une des journaux
elle était restée coincée pendant toute
une semaine dans les élastiques d'un
masque jetable
une fois porté ces masques aussi faim
soit ils peuvent mettre des centaines
d'années à se décomposer et ils sont
particulièrement problématique pour les
animaux des fonds marins selon les
organisations écologistes plus d'un
milliard et demi de masques ont atterri
dans les océans l'an dernier vous allez
voir dans cette vidéo il se promène
partout ce virus là voyez les en rouge
bien voyant dans la rue et il a le don d
frayer chaque humain qu'il croise ses
métaphores mme la situation sanitaire à
on essaye de se protéger tant bien que
mal et le virus court toujours alors
vous allez voir les professionnels s'y
mettre ici ils essayent de l'attraper
avec défilé a crevé trois papillons
c'est pas bien identifiés dans la
réalité on est plutôt sur un traitement
sur le vaccin
on est au pays de pasteur il ya des
crétins qui pensent que le vaccin
messi avait pas eu le vaccin contre la
rage aurait eu des milliers et des
milliers morts il ya des crétins qui
pensent que le court nous on doit pas se
faire vacciner a tant pis pour eux
qu'est ce que je vous dis mais pour les
entend pas beaucoup à la télé j'avais
pas on n'a pas ou la boutique traiteur
ça qui me fait rire qui sont les crises
que ça parce que parce que pour moi ce
sont des crétins l adhésion au vaccin
monte à elle est même majoritaire
maintenant 54 % des français ont
l'intention de recevoir cette injection
ces trois points de plus que la semaine
dernière et c'est notre chiffre du jour
qu'il faudrait c'est parce que je suis
pour faire vaccin oui et puis ceux qui
ne sont pas vaccinés et qu'il chope de
manière grave way qui n'ont voulu mais
qu'il voulait pas je ne veux pas de
vaccin mais bon il soigne chez eux tout
seuls
hier j'avais envie de prendre un petit
café le matin tout simplement faim voilà
de prendre un petit café dans un café
sur une même pas sur une terrasse il
pleuvait mais juste la machine est en
fête
cette année c'est ma plus quoi dire
nous on est des accros au yaourt excusez
moi ils sont tous cassés la valeur d'un
bitcoin a atteint les 40 mille dollars
récemment alors que ce même bitcoin
valait quelques centimes à son lancement
en 2008 résultat ceux qui ont investi
très tôt sont aujourd'hui assis sur un
trésor encore faut-il pouvoir y accéder
la presse américaine relatent de
nombreux cas d' investisseurs qui ont
acheté des bitcoins il ya des années
mais qui ont complètement oublié leur
mot de passe c'est ça qui est
intéressant et bien il passe à côté de
sa fortune mais pour l'éternité car l
inverse justement d'une banque classique
le système du bitcoin où vous propose
aucune solution pour retrouver savez
quoi il n'a pas dû et savez vous avez
perdu votre mot de passe perdu c'est
fini c'est terminé
l'exemple le plus frappant est celui
d'un allemand qui avait acheté 7000
bitcoin en 2011 quand il valait 30
centimes à peine aujourd'hui son
portefeuille vos 220 millions de dollars
problème complètement oublié le mot de
passe il lui reste il lui reste deux
tentatives possibles avant de bloquer
définitivement son compte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon le new york times environ 20% des
bitcoins disponibles seraient dans des
portefeuilles bloquer ou des
portefeuilles on s'appelle rose et ben
oui pour cette même cause parce que
voilà on sait plus on l'a mis par
exemple sur un vieil ordinateur d'un
call avec c'est le cas d'un entrepreneur
de la barbade ça c'est new york times
qui le relate il a émis son opa sur un
ordinateur son collègue la formater
l'ordinateur est là il est en train de
passer à côté de 30 millions de dollars
je cherche du travail oui d'accord pour
moi oui mais attendez quoi cherche dans
l'aéronautique
notez qu'on me dit voilà je suis capable
a écouté une fonction dans le marketing
dans l'aéronautique voilà chez jeanne
passionné engagé donc embauché moi je
suis à madrid et le nom il faut se vend
mieux je travaillerai beaucoup mieux que
oui que les ou que tous les vieux de
scouts mais je vais gérer les dieux
embauche est déjà là
elle fait de la neige c'est la langue
dit à 6 aux états unis la procédure de
destitution de donald trump a été
validée valider oui par la chambre des
représentants l'équivalent en gros nos
députés et donald trump qui devient le
premier président des états unis à faire
l'objet de deux procédures de
destitution pendant son mandat
elle sait maintenant au sénat de voter
ou non son inculpation il sera jugé pour
avoir incité à l'insurrection lors de
l'assaut du capitole la semaine dernière
byron howard a calé loi l'a laissé un
mauvais goût mec c'est spécial c'est
très mauvais goût assez dégueulasse ans
les enfants font flipper on dirait des
papilles ils ont des thèmes de papy
c'est la galerie des horreurs en fait
c'est non non on reconnaît mme à coggia
qui sont quand même elles ça fait avec
les enfants
c'est ok
[Musique]
pardon maintenant je passe en ravalement
de façade
saïd et faire un miracle parce que je
suis routier que me laisse pousser le
ventre et la barbe
après le ventre il vient toucher l'âme
et je fais pas un tout petit atout dans
la rue c'est pas possible pour arrêter
ça si tu vas te baigner tus à emprunter
un petit bout d'al du coin c'est dans la
raie des fesses si ce n'est sa marque
est passée par l'intrigué va pas du tout
avec un gilles julien et puis ça finit
par un choeur c'est ça prenons son mec à
l'entrée de ses fesses en fait c'est
horrible ccvo guerre c'est pas beau
c'est n'importe quoi
sarah notre situation aujourd'hui vous
êtes heureuse en ce que vous êtes en
couple qui s'est pas indiscret très bien
mais elle n'est pas obligée de réponse
est faux le savoir non mais c'est pas ça
ce n'était pas le but de la question
n'est ce pas vraiment de très mauvais
goût vu le thème de notre fondateur
maintenant vu le thème de notre débat ce
serait très mauvais goût
[Musique]
chaque année le championnat du monde du
cri de la mouette c'est ça en 2019
justin remporté le championnat haut la
main
depuis elle s'est confrontée aux plus
grands notamment l'humoriste jamel
debbouze sur facebook
la championne en titre et les
organisateurs appellent tous les
participants à leur envoyer une vidéo de
leur meilleure éducation
[Musique]
alors tous à vos smartphones
le comité attend vos plus belles vidéos
sur facebook
la neuvième édition de championnat du
monde du cri de la mouette aura lieu le
14 février prochain